okay so we're back here we're in the
future yeah we were saying before the
one question the people in the future
are gonna have is why did you think we
were so into silver uh Melissa
harris-perry as a professor do you find
there is a culture of political
correctness on college campuses that is
stifling debate and learning hmm I don't
but I do
I do think students are um no atmosphere
of political correctness on campus I
don't find that no whoa where do you
teach I teach at Wake Forest University
um but I do think the students are
struggling with this and I and I feel
like um because lots of comedians would
even play colleges anymore cuz nothing's
funny
oh yes not that that's not been in my
experience I mean I was telling that
I've got these 22 students and we went
to Iowa New Hampshire both South
Carolina primaries in North Carolina
primary they're Democrats and
Republicans and I would assign them to
work for candidates even if they didn't
if they're not from that party and they
threw themselves into it so I had you
know Republicans working for Bernie and
you know Democrats working for Rubio and
they they were very much into it but
they are struggling with it and we don't
have good language for talking to each
other across difference and I don't know
that we're doing a good job in this
country giving our young people good
tools for having conversations across
difference but I think that's our fault
not theirs
as always nothing's there for you for
Scott how does Isis employ tactics of
persuasion well the whole thing is
persuasion right because they're trying
to convince people to literally kill
themselves for something in the future
but what's interesting is that I'm not
sure we're using the same kind of
persuasion against them because bombing
them isn't you know changing their minds
if anything it's probably hardening
their resolve but if you look at Trump's
approach for example the same tools he
uses I'm not saying that Trump needs to
do it but those tools would work with
Isis you know if you adjusted them for
the cultural difference I mean basically
you just here's what I would do I would
take a nicest person or
somebody you thought might be become one
somebody who's kind of got the mindset I
would hook him up to whatever kind of
brain you know scanners we have so we
can see what their mental activity is in
which part of the brain is lighting up
and then I would a be test I'd say how
about this idea what happens when you
think this and I would just find out
what lit up because you could literally
persuade them out of it and by the way
you don't have to persuade it all has
something to do with the Koran don't you
think um oops people have to believe it
right right so seriously if you've been
reading that book like and sometimes
only that book since you could read 20%
of the world time you do it the 20% of
people can be talked down into anything
with persuasion sure and if you if you
flipped 20% of Isis they start having a
problem all right so you don't have to
get them all you just have to give them
but not everyone can be hypnotized right
cuz someone once tried to hypnotize me
and it was not happening
yeah and I want and I want it to be well
maybe you think you weren't but no I was
do you think you ended up in that outfit
so about 20% of people can have a deep
hypnosis where they see things that
aren't there hear things the rest of us
can be influenced so if they were trying
to influence you it probably would have
worked if you stuck with it whatever you
were trying to accomplish but no not
everybody goes into a deep trance okay
Michael what do you make of Germany's
decision to allow turkish President
Erdogan to prosecute a comedian who
wrote a controversial poem yeah uh it's
a travesty that didn't get nearly as
much coverage because um will tell us
the story well the story is basically
this I mean you know the problems that
we have of comedians as you put it in
this country is that Jerry Seinfeld
won't go to plant ecology Jerry desert
he's not doing like really risque
material you know he won't go to college
but it's slightly different in Western
Europe is supposedly a bastion of
democracy and a Turkish comedian who
lives in German he's the resident of
Germany as a passport made a wrote a
poem that was rather rude and pretty
funny about Erewhon
and he's being put on trial in Germany
and an old law at the request of erawan
and so the government of Germany
obliged Erewhon who's a knuckle-dragging
dictator and he they decided to put a
court and this kind of sort of you know
abrogation of rights in Western Europe
is chipping away at speech is totally
insane and so much so that when that
happened I didn't even write a column
about it because it's just like that
would be used to be the thing that would
it's not enough so much anymore it's not
bigotry to stand up for liberalism no
it's a Muslim is good and now it's not
our values like freedom of speech and
separation of church and state and
respect for minorities and women as
equal citizens those are good things
there's a very very good thing yeah a
story today it's not our fault no it's
not it's not as when it when there is
you know when there people in different
cultures don't follow those things and
they say that they're just a different
culture there was a story today yeah
acqua see it's worse it's it's much
worse and I say that from the future
yeah where I've seen what happened
alright should Congress allocate more
funding to help us prepare for the Zika
virus spreading here well I heard today
there is a another bug that is
absolutely untreatable by antibiotics so
I I'm more worried about that one than I
am about Zika but yes absolutely more
funding because sounds so cute it sounds
like a pop star right it's a Sicilian
mobster right yeah I think is got the
beats
right yeah
Scott how do we make ourselves less
vulnerable to tricks of Master
persuaders the weird thing about
persuasion is people can tell you what
they're doing and doing it right in
front of you and it still works so the
you know things are priced at a dollar
ninety-nine and everybody knows all
you're trying to make me think it's less
than two dollars and it still works
let's do it right so the the answer is
there really is no defense do you think
Trump's gonna win I think he's gonna win
it in a landslide the election the
general election and have said that
since last summer and it's because of
tools not because of policies per se of
course but you Wow
that's can i interject you yes I agree I
was the first guy in the country of
predicted Trump would win and I think
it'll be a landslide it's because of the
economy as much as his branding his
persuasion and anything else you
attribute I commute economy is horrible
and completely there's less people are
angry interset here's the way to phrase
and it was so the fault of Obama said
who took over when we were losing
800,000 jobs a month there's two
terrible presidents back-to-back Bush
and Obama they both had to a horrible
death to the country
jet is poisoned debt will destroy every
country touches Russia netted four
trillion Obama added nine trillion by
the time you leave store eleven trillion
we have too much I have too much debt
but just know economists we're nice the
debt in itself is bad no economist well
this single biggest threat to America
isn't terrorism the national security
it's a debt crisis just like Greece just
a good red is the environment but look
at Venezuela well there has to be bad
guy has to be bad at some level it is I
just said that you did debt is bad
someone is well as socialism leads to
people that there is a toilet there is
no one who ever went to economics school
who would say we should have no debt I
didn't say we should have known okay I
certainly would like us to cut our debt
dramatically okay uh will Britain leave
the European Union and what would the
repercussions be if they did oh well
that's a that's a brain teaser hey uh I
don't think I'd be good I mean it would
I was reading about this recently and it
certainly would be a lot of not a good
thing for a lot of the people who came
know anything yet k to work I'm not
going to be kicking this is essentially
the problem in Europe is that you know
this is this is breaking apart the
Conservative Party in England in her
Prime Minister David Cameron it was a
stay man and the man who's opposing him
Boris Johnson you know wants to pull out
of the European right but there's so
much of this stuff and like this this
idea of the Schengen Agreement we can
travel you go to Europe you don't have
to have a passport you just go here to
there after the Paris attacks people
started really questioning why this why
these people can come into Greece and
move so freely throughout Europe so that
actually buckled this idea that the
European unis a great thing so
everything that the kind of confidence
in European Union after the debt crisis
was then compounded again by the fact
that terrorists were moving freely
throughout Europe so you know I don't
think it can be a great thing if it
pulls out but people are very very
European of traveling to Europe those
days are just about Oh
might soon be up and I would ask the
question again I'm gonna bring up the
dead again why should why should middle
class be
hallucinations pay for hurry you do real
early in Spain why do they pay for the
rain yes you do realize that trumps
economic plan would increase the debt no
I don't realize exactly until cut
spending he want any but he will cut
spending even if he cut spending to
nothing
dis discretionary spending not the
spending that is already promised he it
would increase by 8 trillion dollars
over the next 10 years because he wants
to cut taxes like they all do my
argument is there's no way to save
America we're going down unless you give
Greece growth you've got it dramatically
expand growth this is good only crease
growth by cutting taxes and cutting
regulations Reagan did it and Trump will
be another regular ok look great
I miss that I'd love to hear that they
on Judas like at the Bob Dylan come yeah
part some people I went online that part
of what was interesting me about what
Michael was saying around the question
of Europe that again I think we don't
want to miss by simply arguing around
the Trump piece because I think he's
just such an easy target to just make it
about Trump and then we miss that this
like the anxiety about the outsiders and
the anxiety about the economy is not
only not just a trump problem it's also
not just an American problem and so like
you're like it's this big question about
how we're going to have to change a big
international conversation about what is
public what is government for who who is
the we and like these are things that I
think we're going to have to be able to
do better than just a partisan
conversation just a conversation that
happens in the context of an election
these are presentations about should we
are borders that's the biggest question
the world needs to be banning or do you
have what they're porous and people are
poring over the Europe and America
poring over the Morrigan another thing
that worrying over what I think you
Michael do a different answer on that
but they're pouring over not pouring all
our net immigration from Mexico has been
zero since 2007 again a fact
I know facts don't get when you want to
give her the TSA earlier
I think they're not boring you see one
of the evils of shakeout selection -
Melissa's point is that American
politics is actually becoming more
European eyes the idea that now we have
our nice hand Bernie Sanders is a social
democrat right you have a mainstream
liberal and on the right you have a
populist candidate you have the
mainstream Paul Ryan types that is
something that every European country
deals with those long dealt with because
they're parliamentary democracies and
they have coalition government rage and
this is we are not becoming more
European just because of Bernie Sanders
we're becoming more European in every
possible way with this kind of fractured
two-party systems or socially leaning
apart in so many ways and socially I
just don't want us to like miss like the
magician hypnotist trick of like look
over here at the shiny thing while the
real thing is going over here that I'm
the shiny indeed sir you are the shiny
thing uh last question does the hubbub
over bathroom laws in conservative
states mean the nation is less United
over social issues than we thought well
I thought the the culture wars might
have been over and it looks like maybe
not quite yet because they are pretty
upset about but the fact that like three
people you know will be using a bathroom
that wouldn't be the bathroom that they
started to use when they were born but
this is like the battle in New Orleans
at the end of the war of 1812 when
nobody had told them that it was over it
was just at this final battle and
there's like someone came on horseback
like a week later you know it's done
this is the last gasp of a 90s culture
world like the different response man
guys are so elitist I'm for gay rights
I'm for gay marriage transgender your
leaders way too far you're pushing
middle-class people beyond the point
they're gonna go I'm just telling the
truth you're pushing them be long
willing play dumb issue for the tajalli
shove it here could add too far to fall
on their story I don't you've seen a
different way I live in North Carolina
and so HB 2 gets passed and what's
fascinating to me is it ain't a big
fight because the next day the entire
like system of the economy all the
National folks I mean folks came so the
that same state legislature had passed
all of these bills that were deeply
troubling and problematic around for
example voter ID and the country was
kinda like but as soon as HB 2 happens
the n-c-double-a the NBA all were like
oh hell no I bet you you won't and they
all with complete clarity said we're not
come and do business that's your North
Carolina totally right you know with
that right so what I'm saying is that
ain't a culture war at the point at
which they extract economic costs from
the state it changes the calculus
dramatically and it really does feel
much more like Michaels point that it is
it feels much more like the last gasp
when in fact when corporate America is
on the side of knob we really don't play
that then it's really not beyond
remotely possible it's totally fair and
I agree with you I'm for free markets
capitalism and put them out of business
great put North Carolina business but
guess what it's gonna backfire because
target someone is going to be out of
business with Europe no moratorium might
be out of business but you're janus your
base in fact I know that Donald Trump
said katelynn jet ski throws them to use
and to me it's meet an issue invitation
with him I just okay
well that's cuz you don't have bathroom
problem but no whew then thank God I got
to go right now thank you very much
everybody
you